ground control to Major Tom ground
control to Major Tom pilot to Bombardier
pilot to Bombardier this is the [__]
burn the [__] smoke before he died you
know I'm saying let's do this [__]
Monday the 23rd do what you need to do
the world don't wait for no one you
understand me so either you up you're
ready to go
[__] is this [__] there you go getting
this thing together for you [__]
so there's no misunderstanding you
understand me
it's Monday [__]
cool it's Monday [__] I got
this [__] that kills Vern the [__]
alright be run is dead but I don't feel
so good myself
yeah I'm saying [__] it tip-top Magoo
Monday April the 23rd slinging dick and
giving our [__] new chunks that's how
we're coming out of the [__] box
today I'm sorry I hadn't seen you
[__] for six days but I've been
busy at number two I had to cut you off
the umbilical cord just to set you out
to enter a world free to see how you
react people begging me everyday hit me
up on but what the [__] I got [__] going
on there's a crack-a-lackin' but let me
tell you something it's Monday and it's
all the same nothing but elbows and
[__] somebody sucking your dick
today you're leaving the house like a
[__] magician you know I'm saying
with a rabbit in your hat or sticking
your hand and a big dick between your
legs because you don't give a [__] jack
you showing up with a tuxedo uncle Joey
here I want to thank Columbus Ohio for
the great [__] weekend five sold-out
shows you savages Kate Quigley for
taking it home next stop Tempe Arizona
you understand me
November I mean November what the [__]
am I talking about this weed is
tremendous mace 3rd 4th and 5th Cinco
DeMayo weekend not that I don't thank
that what are you [__] nuts or what
the birds are singing the sun's out kid
2 chirping whatever the [__] going on
and I'm down just like you [__]
cuz you don't give a [__] they can't
hold you down you've been sitting on
that couch debating what you gonna do
with your life a finger that's what
you're gonna do your life Bing God
they're gonna call you Johnny P mu you
know what that means in Cuban a big
[__] dick and you show up 10 minutes
before the [__] situation but Joey
what's with the [__] ear bleeding on
Monday would you smoke a pound there's a
team but now I'm warmed up I've been up
since 6:00 ready to stab a [__]
immigrant mentality in full effect
I got a little workout I got a little
meeting I got some writing I got some
acupuncture
I got a podcast I got a weigh-in at
Weight Watchers I got a spot tonight
that's my [__] day plus I got to be a
dad
plus I gotta make calls plus I gotta let
mother [__] there's no but I'm not
[__] around you understand me I
didn't get here just to [__] around so I
suggest if you're the little box over
the weekend your basketball team lost
your hockey team who gives a [__] it's
Monday it's a whole new week and a whole
new [__] set of rules I got two
different weaves today I got the [__] to
kill burn the [__] when I got this
[__] debt where do I get it from
sunset early I only deal with [__]
Armenians by the way my heart goes out
to the Armenian it's the whole [__]
thing they're parading tomorrow wish I'd
go down there but [__] I got things
that doing people to see black minions I
got my heart behind you you know I love
your [__] if you don't have an
Armenian friend and [__] LA you got
nothing you follow me I got three Jews
and two Armenians and my disposal ready
to stab a [__] anyway
I'm here ah
tremendous you getting all this [__] out
of our bombs from the weekend the
[__] airplane with those disgusting
people they don't clean these [__]
planes before you get on people getting
off international flights with turbans
on and [__] gadget [__]
the Japs know what's going on they got
the [__] mask on but everybody else
they don't even Lysol these [__]
things you walk them right into there
that's why your [__] immune systems
gotta be tip-top on glue you gotta get
the acupuncture from your insurance
you gotta get to take a meal before you
fly you can't be smoking with these
[__] bronchitis people you you want
to be a [__] you know but next thing
you know you're coughing your eyeball
out because these people don't tell you
they've just been sick for three [__]
weeks that's why you got to eat ass you
got to swim in the Hudson you got to
build your [__] immune system just
like guys that I don't give a [__] jack
hepatitis C herb all that [__] that
sucked my dick uncle Joey's here it's
[__] Monday and we're ready to stab
somebody just in case you ever been in
that position just in case you know I
gotta [__] I got a pencil what a
[__] razor at the end prison stuff
this is what it's all about family I'm
with you you with me and they want to be
with us you understand me we don't give
a [__] we go out there on a daily and
lay our hearts and [__] balls on the
[__] line and then you go home I do
they and no I failed today but I know I
did something somebody's gonna remember
me somebody's gonna call don't worry
about nothing I'm saying that's all I
can tell you it's [__] Monday what
else you want from me a [__] find our
bill get the [__] out of here get up
wash your [__] cut your toenails put
your [__] best suit on and go out
there and walk in the room like you got
the biggest dick in the room who gives a
[__] fake it fake it fake it to the funk
whatever these [__] Gentiles fake it
and I don't [__] fake it
we don't fake nothing we go in there cuz
we mean [__] business you understand
but we don't think nothing nobody face
here you want to fake be a [__] actor
and throw sidekicks today look at me
they'll [__] out of here
I'm on stage no director no producer I'm
the producer the director the [__]
writer and the guy up there [__]
sweating bullets with [__] anxiety so
[__] these [__] I suggest you do
the same it's Monday [__] whatever
happened last week happened last we get
a second chance of making your life
happen today
who gives a [__] what they think they're
not there when you're [__] paying for
groceries are they no they're not there
when you're [__] paying right now Dan
out there yeah you know what I'm saying
anyway one more ball and we tell you
what not I'm getting a [__] eye out
here Oh this refrain [__] around these
are both indicas of debt this is the one
I do type [__] and that's it remember oh
yeah they didn't come on my team up
bingo and Luna bother Monday's a crucial
day today's the day you lay the [__]
groundwork down today's the day you let
[__] know you're there to
[__] throw down roll up your sleeves
you don't give a [__] you don't give a
[__] who gives in to throw you in jail
go in there tell them all to suck your
dick and [__] you make a mistake you get
up you rub your [__] knees you put a
bandaid on and you go back out there you
understand me that's it and that's that
it's [__] Monday [__] enough with
your [__] lies and [__] write out
what you gonna do and go do it and
that's it it's that [__] easy Aaron
that's it I'm [__] scum I don't know
what you guys gave me
you guys gotta cut this [__]
anyway I'll see you [__] this
afternoon ready to go with a podcast
start off the day correctly remember
that didn't get my Michael on bingo go
get with the way they go out some DC
might go to eat or bottle I'm sorry I
miss a comment or email from tell of go
holy Raya so if you know what I'm saying
that's how you gotta leave the house
thinkin you gotta roll your eyes nothing
wrong colorful on a wire and then you
got an alley anyway then people money
put it out on yourself I love you
[__] the Church of what's
happened now we got Nick Gregorius the
brilliant jujitsu [__] master one of
my buddies I've he's been a mentor told
me online I love him on the podcast
Wednesday he's doing a little seminar up
and [__] subconscious up there and no
hold on Lancashire I'm 7 o'clock
Thursday night whatever the [__] you are
show up I'm gonna be there [__]
throwing sidekicks for Jesus that's my
main man but anyway I love you guys with
all my heart I have a great day don't
let nobody [__] with you remember I told
you your world man it's your world all
these [__] are just visiting if
you leave the house thinking like that
today
ciao that's the beginning of a [__]
lifetime what are you scared of
take a chance Columbus did Bolton have a
good day